this moment has such a beautiful
crescendo with you and mr chadwick
boseman where you're talking about
you're trying to communicate this story
about a bus from tallahassee
it's at a very low energy and then
suddenly it erupts
into a physical altercation what was it
like
what was it like playing that scene with
him staging that scene getting into that
with him
i i think the thing that i know about
all of our characters
especially chadwick and my character as
well everyone walked in with their own
pressure cooker
emma moz is just raging she's just full
fire and heat and sweat you know
and cutler is on a low simmer
just a very low simmer the whole time
and i think you can tell from the very
beginning that there is um
there's going to be a clash of ideology
there's going to be a clash in the way
we do things
it starts off the moment levy enters the
room and says
i bought me some shoes and cutlass like
and he bought it
with cutler's money you know
so already they're like there's already
this
they keep missing each other um i do
feel that they have a lot in common and
they respect each other
but i think that they're on pushing each
other a little bit
like le levy's coming in he is
definitely
um it's it has an intention
to be the disrupter and cutler is trying
to keep everything in line
and even when he tells that story in
that moment that you're saying
all cutler has is his faith he's a man
of faith
and he believes in it fully and then
levy's character presents
his receipts based on the story that
color cutler said
he's he challenges cutler by saying god
hates [ __ ]
guys take his [ __ ] dreams and film in
the garbage guy don't care nothing about
you
and that cuts cutlass to his core
why i think possibly because he may
believe that levy could be right
and then where does that leave a man who
all he has
is faith so it's about i love that
august wilson puts the challenge of
god's will
right in the middle of the play and and
that's not something that's
often done with uh black characters you
know everyone's always like oh lord yes
lord
in a in falling in line but here's the
character in the center who's saying
question it
i question it because my receipts show
differently
he said my experience is my mother was
raped in front of me
i was cut across my chest
where was god when these terrible things
happen
i question that he exists in cutler
it it i i think the reason why cutler
hits levy
is as if he's trying to stop the sound
he's like don't say
any more because i won't be able to live
on this earth
especially as a black man in 1927 who
has he only has power in this man
because of ma
so he's he's under someone else's power
he doesn't truly feel that he has agency
in the world
he plays in a um and a band that just
plays you know
very simple music you know what i mean
it is a basically the cover band in a
way
you know but and you have someone who's
trying to buck the whole system
and cutler is not for it at all um
that was a beautiful scene to play with
chad it was absolutely beautiful because
we had to give it our all
we had to leave no stone unturned and we
had to put
coleman and chadwick into the scene as
well
when we did that scene chadwick stopped
halfway through because he was so
bubbled up with emotion
and i yelled at him tell me tell me tell
me
i refused to let him get out of the
scene whatever was going on with him i
wanted it
in this action and i've never done that
before
but i felt like i had permission
the room felt like it was like no we're
going there let's go there
and he does and then i hit him and then
george calls cut and immediately without
a thought
we wrapped our arms around each other
and we sobbed
so we had to go on the brink together
and i had to
make sure my brother chad
could continue to deliver on the promise
that he set up for himself
i didn't know chad was struggling like
he was
no one knew but i look back now to be
honest and
i do know i can tell that possibly in
that moment there was a
struggle with the words that you were
about to say
and what you're possibly dealing with
and the questions that lie in all of our
hearts
when you're when
difficult things land in your lap that
you can't make sense of
why am i dealt this deck why did this
happen to me
i know i felt that way when i lost my
mom and my dad in the same year
right when i was done passing strange
and i thought well why me why does this
happen to me
and my answer for myself was like why
not me
but i still have faith and i think
chadwick does
is what did as well but there's always
those questions
you do question god you know um
i think any healthy person do quite you
do question once in a while
um based on the ills of the world and
what you see and you wonder
but yes still you you hang in there and
you try to have faith because we need
some faith to get through these
these um i don't want to say these dark
times because i don't believe we live in
dark times
i believe we live in challenging times
and they've always been challenging
times and i think that's just part of
life
and this is what we're dealt and we just
have to find the light as much as we can
how did i get on that i have no idea